so my name is jason quinn chef owner of
playground playground 2.0 where we're
standing right now and uh doe exchange
our bakery next door uh today we are all
about foie gras we're going to show four
different varieties of how it can be
prepared or served uh and hopefully take
some flawed virgins and turn them into
believers
[Music]
you look at the way that foie gras is
produced in turkey or hungary where
ducks are nailed down through their feet
and they never move their whole lives
and they have a tube down their throat
just fed it's pure evil where we get our
foie gras from these are ducks that run
wild they're not in cages as a
restaurant owner it is our place to
provide things that people want to eat
my problem with the van of it was not
that foie gras was legal it's that
someone was telling you what you could
or couldn't eat and that was what i felt
was the reason to stand up against it is
more about the fact that people should
be able to eat what they like and if you
don't want to eat it no one's ever going
to make you do it so this is the smoked
foie gras with a little bit of radish
watercress bourbon barley maple syrup
she said to pick it up i don't know i'm
going to pick it up
i have to say like i wanted to not like
this like i really wanted to not like it
but it's kind of awesome
it's both salty and sweet i don't know
how to explain the foie part of it
it's like almost like a animal butter
yeah
yeah it's like animal butter animal
butter yeah
wait that was raw just cold smoke yeah i
feel like if i would have remembered
that when i ate it i would have been
like creeped out but it was so good are
we ready for the next course yeah yeah
this one is uh
foie gras with rhubarb jam
uh and ginger snap cookie and this is
called torson
i think when it's cold like this you get
a lot of the subtlety of the flavor
whereas when you try it hot in a few
minutes you're gonna find it's basically
just warm fat it melts like butter but
it's a liver how is this happening i
thought i wouldn't like it by itself but
i think it's seriously really good just
straight up by itself you think is it
like melts in your mouth but not in your
hands no it'll melt in your hand
yeah what are you doing right here this
is the pan pan seared foie gras with uh
the inka corn the sumo tangerines and
tandoori oil
you know when it's cooked it's a lot
less creamy
i think i like this better than when
it's like uh cold
yeah i guess
it tastes more meaty yeah yeah
you've made this scene very civilized
they kind of came into this thinking it
would be like a uh
you know people would be throwing like
spitting food out and you know well this
is with a yuzu ponzu so ponzu is just
like a situated soy sauce with a fresh
yuzu juice which is a citrus and some
puffed rice on there for texture it's
like it got rice crispies on it
[Music]
dude this is the best one by far this is
so good wins
if you lied to me and told me like this
is a piece of steak
i just feel like this is the best steak
i've ever had
yeah i don't
mind the way it's produced because
everything else we eat meat wise is
produced
in a much worse way than four guys i
think
what i thought was that what's happening
how jason said in some countries was
happening everywhere um
so it's a little comforting to know that
that's not the way that they're all
being treated you know to eat meat and i
love meat you have to
not think about how it's prepared that
much maybe a little too rich for me that
last dish i was glad it was my last one
of the day because i think i need to go
take a nap after that what up dude yeah
marty flaw marty
for florida get quad okay
what the [ __ ]
what's the [ __ ]
[Music]